[Music]  this is lucas the andean condor  with wings that spread up to 10 feet  apart the andean condor is one of the  largest flying birds in the world  found throughout the andes mountains the  condor is a national symbol of many  south american countries  the condor has a hairless head which  changes color depending on their  emotional state  in the male there is a fleshy crest on  the crown of their head used to attract  females  it is also one of the longest living  birds with some condors living for more  than 70 years  it is a scavenger bird traveling over  100 miles a day to find carcasses along  the andes mountains and sometimes all  the way into the south american coast  the condor population is in decline  mostly due to the destruction of its  natural habitat as well as lead  poisoning from carcasses shot by hunters  this is the andean condor